[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette édition du 78 lactu du
vendredi 7 février comme tous les jours
nous allons faire le point sur
l'actualité locale en deuxè partie du
journal nous consacreront une page
spéciale aux élections municipales avec
François de maierre candidat à sa propre
succession sur la commune de Versailles
bonjour François de maierre merci d'être
là tout d'abord cette information météo
suite au passage de la tempête cumerra
sur le département des Yvelines cette
nuit les sapeurs pompiers ont dû
intervenir à peu près une cinquantaine
de fois sur la voie publique notamment
pour des chutes de câble électrique mais
aucune intervention majeure à signaler à
noter qu'en Île-de-France un peu moins
de 10000 foyers se sont retrouvés sans
électricité nous vous l'annoncions la
semaine dernière 1400 suppressions de
poste che airb Airbus groupe
anciennement appelé EADS sont à prévoir
d'ici 3 ans sur le site d'élancour
notamment on parlait de 411 emplois
touchés en cause la restructuration du
groupe qui comprendra trois divisions
parmi elles ADS qui regroupera Cassidian
et Astrium ce qui nous concerne
directement 309 l'emploi également
touché au Mureau a priori mais pour le
syndicat CFE CGC ces chiffres sont à
prendre avec des pincettes car les
effectifs de salariés avancés pour
chaque site lors de cette annonce ne
correspondrai pas à la réalité
explication avec Philippe vanglace
directeur syndical chez cassidan il y a
un chiffre de 411 qui a été fait enfin
annoncé c'est un chiffre que donne la
direction mais ce chiffre pour moi il il
veut rien dire en tous les cas je sais
pas si ça concerne cassidien SAS je ne
sais pas si ça concerne que hencour en
faisant des plus et des moins il y a
notre filiale qui est sur hencour qui
fait plus 156 personnes dans 2 ans donc
si on dit que les 411 ça tient compte
qu'il y en a 156 qui sont placés là on
monte à 560 suppression de poste nous ce
qui nous intéresse c'est les
suppressions de postees c'est pas le
bilan final donc on a beaucoup de mal à
suivre ce que ça veut dire 411
aujourd'hui le 41 je sais pas à qui il
s'applique à quel contour est-ce que
c'est aussi notre filiale absis qui à
Suren ou pas j'en sais rien 1 an et demi
c'est le retard qu'accuse aujourd'hui le
bailleur social au Pivois pour la
deuxème tranche de rénovation du
quartier valiibbou à plaisir un retard
qui serait dû à la nouvelle législation
sur la miante même si les locataires et
la municipalité entendent accélérer les
choses Olivier manisalco et Jonathan
villman se sont rendus sur
place regardez-moi çais 20 ans vraiment
on vit dans la misère c'est incroyable
regardez-moi à plaisir les habitants du
quartier valibou en ont assez prévu au
départ en novembre 2012 la deuxème
tranche des travaux de rénovation de la
résidence HLM n'a toujours pas débuté et
pour les locataires la situation est
devenue indécente il y a des rats il y a
du cafard il y a de la miante vraiment
si nous voulons un organisme
départemental qui vient pour voir quand
même c'est des êtres humains qui vent
dans un quartier aujourd'hui les
habitants demandent clairement des
comptes au bailleurs social la société
au Pivois un bailleur qui justifie son
retard par une nouvelle législation sur
le désamentage des bâtiments avant tout
travaux afin de protéger les
travailleurs qui effectueront cette
rénovation cette nouvelle législation
nous a train à passer des marchés
publics puisque nous sommes un office
qui travaille avec uniquement des
marchés publics marchés public c'est
plutôt long à monter et donc tous ces
éléments
supplémentaires nous ont fait prendre du
retard dans cette réhabilitation si
opivois se déclare de bonne fois
certains jugent le délai des diagnostics
sur la miante beaucoup trop long du côté
de la municipalité on souhaite
clairement accélérer les démarches j'ai
lancé des démarches déjà l'opivo ç une
grande diatribe de ma part assez
virulente aujourd'hui j'ai j'ai vraiment
envie que l'opivois nous regarde et nous
respecte et respecte les habitants selon
opivois la tranche de des travaux et ses
450 logements à rénover ont 90 % de
chance de commencer fin 2014 il devrait
durer 2
ans nous ouvrons désormais notre page
spéciale j'en parlais en début d'édition
municipal évidemment avec François de
Maier candidat à versaill à sa propre
succession bonjour François de BCI nous
avo vous avez déclaré il y peu temps le
janvier dans une interview accordée à no
confrères du Parisien que vous vous
représentier par passion de votre ville
qu'est-ce qui vous passionne tant à
Versailles sachant que vous avez déjà
annoncé un petit peu que vous allez vous
mettre en retrait sur votre députation
notamment ah ben c'est une ville
exceptionnelle versaill est connu dans
le monde entier pour son château mais
c'est également une très belle ville et
puis c'est des habitants qui sont très
attachants donc vous savez quand vous
êtes mare c'est un c'est une fonction
absolument passionnante extrêmement
exigeante qui demande je pense beaucoup
d'ailleurs euh de professionnalisme en
réalité parce que c'est un véritable
métier si on est élu mais il faut aussi
avoir les compétences nécessaires pour
l'exercer et je dois dire que j'adore ce
métier euh vous avez fait pendant votre
mandat une de vos prior de vos priorités
pardon c'était l'urbanisme euh il y a eu
les travaux de l'hôpital richot
notamment la cour des centurs qui qui a
été refaite peut-être au détriment
d'autres projets je pense à chantier ou
à satori des quartiers où il y a eu
peut-être des choses un peu moins
priorisées non non si vous voulez nous
on avait pris un certain nombre
d'engagements c'est d'ailleurs l'objet
de mon deuxième tra de la campagne c'est
de dire qu'on a tenu nos engagements mon
équipe et moi-même nous étions
extrêmement attachés à faire ce qu'on
avait dit et je pense que maintenant où
il faut juger finalement qui va
continuer pendant 6 ans à gérer la ville
ce qui est important c'est que les gens
regardent
ce que nous avions dit il y a 6 ans et
ce que l'on a réellement réalisé et je
dirais pas ce que vous avez dit au
contraire je dirais que nous avons fait
très attention à ce que tous les
quartiers de Versailles soient concernés
par de nouveaux amements de de nouveaux
embellissements et on pourrait les
lisser ça serait très très long vous
avez parlé de richot c'est un projet
majeur mais il y en a bien d'autres et
aucun quartier n'a été délaissé les
quartiers sociau ont été aussi tout à
fait concernés par cette vague de de
nouveau aux investissements il y a
peut-être un point positif c'est le
maintien de de du tarif au niveau des de
l'imposition ça c'est quelque chose
auquel vous tenez particulièrement oui
je crois qu'aujourd'hui dans une période
de crise on nous demande d'être très
raisonnable au fond si vous voulez il
faut être ambitieux et en même temps
avoir toujours les yeux rivés sur la
dépense publique pour que l'on
maintienne la fiscalité au niveau le
plus bas possible depuis 3 ans on n'a
pas augmenté les impôts on n' pas
augmenté de centimes à iitionnel pour la
ville de Versailles les impôts vous
savez c'est aussi le cumule un certain
nombre d'autres éléments notamment les
bases fiscales qui sont décidé par
l'État mais nous ville nous n'avons
jamais augmenté les impôts depuis 3 ans
vous vous représentez donc à cette
élection en 2014 lors de ce scrutin à
Versailles cela va peut-être ressembler
quand même à une bataille à droite non
avec ces listes qui émergent petit à
petit versaill famille avenir avec
Fabien bouglet Benoît Saint-Cernin qui
vous a soutenu en 2008 et là qui qui
fait sa propre liste écoutez c'est vrai
que les Candat que vous avez évoqué sont
venus me voir en disant est-ce qu'on
pourrait participer à ma liste donc
c'est je pense que d'une certaine façon
ils sont conscients qu'on a fait du bon
travail parce qu'ils souhaitent être
avec nous après malheureusement dans une
équipe on peut pas prendre tout le monde
aujourd'hui ils ont le souhait de mener
leur propre aventure très bien mais ce
qui est important de savoir c'est qu'au
départ il trouvait pas que nous avions
si mal travaillé que ça concernant la la
liste versaill famille avenir vous vous
en parliez ils sont venus vous voir ils
vous ont sollicité Fabien bogl le la
tête de liste C kist là est-ce que ça
vous priverait pas d'une partie de votre
électorat parce que c'est quand même il
y a quand même quelques points communs
non bah il y a beaucoup de points commun
sur la famille c'est vrai que nous nous
avons beaucoup travaillé sur ce terrain
de la famille et puis en tant que
parlementaire je m'étais engagé à
défendre ces sujets et vous savez je
crois que d'ailleurs personne le
conteste et FAM conteste c'est pas je me
suis énormément donné pour là encore
tenir les engagements que j'avais pris
auprès des électeurs j'été très présent
sur ces sujets maintenant si le sujet
famille est essentiel et il sera
essentiel dans les 6 ans qui vont venir
si les versillais renouvellent la
confiance à mon équipe ce n'est pas le
seul sujet et là je suis en désaccord
avec cette liste parce que tout est axé
sur ce seul sujet or je crois que c'est
un élément capital mais c'est loin
d'être le seul d'une politique
municipale par rapport à l'autre liste
Benoît de Saint-Cernin dont vous parliez
il vous a soutenu en 2008 là il montre
sal list je le disais tout à l'heure il
estime que la gestion économique de la
ville pourrait être plus florissante en
tout cas peut-être plus performante vous
avez des progrès à faire là-dessus non
je crois pas ce qui est important c'est
de voir là encore les réalisations bien
sûr on peut toujours se dire qu'il faut
faire mieux et d'ailleurs ça sera notre
objectif essayer toujours faire mieux
mais si objectivement on regarde ce qui
s'est passé en 6 nous avons fait venir
des entreprises de premier plan c'était
pas arrivé depuis longtemps blizard est
aujourd'hui l'un des premiers employeur
privés de Versailles c'est presque 500
emplois ça c'est une réalisation qui a
été fait par notre équipe parce queà un
moment il a fallu allégir extrêmement
vite pour trouver des locaux adéquats
pour blizard vous avez une autre
entreprise s'appelle booking pix là
aussi nous avons dû trouver les moyens
de avec eux trouver un endroit qui
satisfait et Versailles aujourd'hui a
des projets importants notamment sur le
plateau de satori avec le Conseil
Général des ivelines nous avons créé
ensemble une structure porteuse pour
pouvoir bâtir des 7000 m Carr
supplémentaires qui vont accueir des
technologies et à partir de ces
laboratoires de recherche nous espérons
que le projet Vcom sa voiture de demain
va enfin prendre recps quelles sont vos
priorités justement sur cette campagne
là qu'allez-vous dire aux versaillaises
et aux Versaillais alors il y a
plusieurs priorités je vais les
développer au cours de la campagne parce
que vous savez je crois dans une
campagne il faut respecter je le timing
normal timing normal c'est d'abord quand
vous êtes sortant de rendre compte et de
dire voilà ce que nous avons fait voilà
ce qui a été réalisé par rapport aux
promesses qui avait été il y a 6 ans
donné par mon équipe et puis ensuite il
s'agit de faire les propositions les
propositions sont des propositions qui
vont aller dans plusieurs axes mais je
continuerai à être très vigent sur
l'aspect de la gestion parce que il me
semble qu'aujourd'hui dans cette période
de crise il est important d'être le plus
efficace possible avec l'argent que les
contribuables nous donnent ensuite il y
a des domaines sur lesquels on est
particulièrement attentif dans une
période de crise c'est tout le secteur
social et le secteur familial
étant une des des points forts bien sûr
de notre équipe après vous avez pu voir
que Versailles s'est beaucoup développé
dans ces 6 ans notamment avec des
réalisations d'urbanist importantes
parce que au fond ce qui reste après
nous c'est aussi ce que l'on a bâti ce
que l'on a rénové et ça nous
continuerons aujourd'hui Versailles est
cité comme une ville modèle notamment en
matière écologique et l'image on dit
versaill est une ville traditionnelle
mais la réalité c'est qu'il y a à peine
10 jours on venait où ou pour parler
l'écologie contemporaine à Versailles
c'était la ville phare pour tout ce qui
fait dans ce domaine donc vous voyez je
crois que c'est très important d'avoir
toujours ce souci à la fois de valoriser
un passé notre histoire notre patrimoine
qu'on a beaucoup bellli et puis aussi
d'être dans le présent dans la modernité
très bien on a on a compris votre
message François deer merci beaucoup on
suivra évidemment de près la campagne
municipale du côté de Versailles une
dernière information avant de refermer
ce journal la possibilité de relier la
ligne C du RER à saint-sir l'école à la
ligne A de saintgerain Saint-Germain
enlais se concrétise enfin ce jeudi la
préfecture des yvlines a autorisé le
lancement des premières procédures
d'acquisition foncière utile au projet
DESS 2014 un projet de Tram Train
permettra donc de relier les deux villes
en 30 minutes au lieu du double à
l'heure actuelle le projet porté par le
sttif réseau feré de français la SNCF
permettra en 2019 notamment de
transporter 9 à 10 millions de voyageurs
par entre les deux villes merci beaucoup
d'avoir suivi une nouvelle fois ce 78
lactus c'est terminé pour aujourd'hui
n'oubliez pas le 78 weekend pour vos
idées de sorti avec yolen Torres quant à
moi je vous souhaite un excellent
weekend sur TVfil
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tangenti